washington art rodrik anciens marshall
de la police fédérale reçoit un
mystérieux coup de fil à rodrigues que
puis-je faire pour vous la famille de
deux des trois évadés d'alcatraz prend
contact avec l'ancien enquêteur pour la
toute première fois depuis 1962 elle
propose son aide dans cette affaire
restée dans les annales art rodrik a
longtemps participé à l' enquête et
c'est une nouvelle intrigante après plus
d'un demi-siècle de fausses pistes et
d'impasses
les autorités sont en contact avec la
famille depuis l'évasion en 1962 et
depuis tout ce temps on essaie d'avoir
sa coopération
on va jusqu'à aujourd'hui nos
informations sur l'évasion d'alcatraz
avec le service des marshals on est prêt
alors l'affairé